hello
everyone I'm very happy to be with you
today so I'm kolene I'm one of the
co-founders of database and database we
are a small Studio specialized in human
data
interactions uh that means that our job
is to make visible and usable um
information that is contained in very
large volumes of data so we design and
we develop tools or softwares or
application that help people understand
data or interact with data or develop
new use with data and so we created
database with my partners because we
were convinced that our brain doesn't
work like a computer and as humans uh we
need some specific interfaces like
visual interfaces for example to
understand the complexity inside the
data and that's why at database we're
doing a lot of data visualization like
custom made tailor made data
visualization Advanced Data
visualization like the one you see um on
the side which are project we created
during the past years and so just to
finish with the presentation we are a
team of six people at database with a
mix of designers and developers and we
are based in Paris uh in
France so today I'm going to talk about
a tool uh we have been working on since
since the last month and it's called
null it's a tool for mapping very large
Corpus of documents or very large Corpus
of knowledge and it's just a first
prototype for the moment you you are
seeing uh it's first a first prototype
that Maps uh about 30 50,000 scientific
publication about the Corona virus and
with this tool we have a strong ambition
uh really strong ambition we want to
revolutionize the way we uh search for
information in large volumes of document
and so that's the ambition and that's
the talk we be about and now I'm going
to tell you a bit more about how it goes
in real life and how we have been
working on this so what was the trigger
how did we start this patient for search
so well when the Health crisis happened
and the spring we wondered what we could
do as a data visualization expert
because we are not at all expert in
molecular biology nor in virology and we
didn't know how to produce mask but uh
we were good dealing with information
overload and data massification and we
discovered that that was a real problem
during this crisis uh for example we
interviewed ferdinant who is a
postdoctoral researcher in a research
center and he told us that during this
crisis he uh he was flooded with an
evalan of preprints papers and
information and he feel he was stuck by
the amount of data it was impossible for
him to digest uh everything um and he
was not used to that he told us he feels
that uh it's good that there is transpar
transparency about other research works
but uh he was really afraid to waste too
much time if he had as to assess all of
all of this and in fact available
information about Corona viruses have
never been so rich or accessible as it
is now because at the beginning of the
crisis lots of scientific Publishers uh
gave free access to their articles about
Corona virus uh to ease the research
about the disease but they also speed up
the review uh and publication process
for new articles uh and this led to
several thousands of new scientific
papers being published and released each
week during uh the month of April and
May and this is the biggest explosion of
scientific literature ever so that's was
the trigger and now why do we have a
problem because this practice of open
science it has a huge potential it's
really fascinating but it also
introduces A new challenge which is
discoverability so having too much
content too much material uh we risk
missing something important uh something
we will not find because it's drawn into
the mass of information for example F he
told us that he's often afraid of
missing an article that already exists
about uh the subject he's working on and
for him checking if something already
exists or not in the massive amount of
already published scientific papers it's
it's really complicated it's it's cost
too much time he told us and this
discoverability problem uh it can have
very concrete impact so let's just talk
about
one uh it has already claimed lives
during the ebora CR in 2013 for example
this is a story told by beris Dan who is
the chief medical officer of Liberia's
Ministry of Health uh so it's in an
article published in the New York Times
and she explained that during the uh the
the 80s the early 80s there have been
already one scientific work that pointed
out that Liberia uh needs to be included
in the area where the Ebola virus uh was
onemic
and this scientific work was already
warning for the risk of an epidemic and
risk of a pandemic but this work as uh
was published in some European medical
journals uh which are really more
confidential than the English ones and
so it has remained unknown to local
health authority in Liberia and so
that's how we uh had this crisis with
the Ebola pandemic in Liberia which cost
some lives in in Africa
and so this is a terrible example of
what we call dark knowledge and dark
knowledge this is the part of the
scientific knowledge that cannot be
found or cannot be reached or cannot be
used so back to our Corona virus
examples among the scientific
publication we have been working on for
this project so the the publication that
have been open and published during the
crisis we estimate that 50% have never
been quoted no mentioned by any the
scientific work and we've also
discovered that at least 6% of this
publication um in not in English but in
Chinese or Korean or Arabic Russian so
those publication who are not which are
not in English they will probably never
be found by any American researcher or
any European researcher if it's not the
same language and that's always a
problem if a research work cannot be
found because maybe this work was
bringing something new and very useful
for all the researchers but also if
several researchers are working at the
same time on the same subject without
knowing it it's it's the it's m of time
they would have been able to save some
pre precious time if they were aware and
so at the end why do do we have this
discoverability problem uh let's look at
what are our tools today to deal with
this discoverability problem most part
of the time researchers are using such
engines like PubMed or scopus but also
Google Google Scholar or Microsoft
academic when they need to look for
scientific papers and according to us
but not only us other researchers have
this opinion those search and joins are
not always the best way to tackle with
this discoverability problem first for
user experience reason because
conventionally the presentation of a
such result uh it's a list paginated
like the one you see here from Google
Scholar but let me ask how many of you
are looking at the result uh located on
the third page of results only the third
page I guess not many people uh and most
part of the time there are hundreds and
hundreds of pages of results so that's a
lot of article that you won't be able to
find second reason it's transparency
reason there are arbitrariness in the
way Google or Google Scholar work but
other suchar Andes also uh because the
ranking algorithm is not
transparent uh we know for example few
things and we already know that there
are some bias for example publication
that are in English language um they are
more likely to be on the top of the list
than other language but also publication
that have been published in a really
well-known reviews or publication that
are already cited by a lot of article
they are more likely to have a good Rank
and more likely to be fun so which is
really good when you are looking for
some conventional definition of a
subject or when you are looking for uh
the common sense what most people are
thinking about a subject but maybe
that's not the best way to take a
critical look at a subject or to have a
deep understanding of a subject or to
find some real material for your
scientific study so maybe we need to
admit that the most efficient search
engine in your day-to-day life when you
need to find a recipe or the title of a
movie or something like that it's not
the best tool for searching for
scientific
information and the last reason I I
wanted to point out is search engine um
they are not always good and in
particular they're not good when you
don't know to this how when you don't
know how to describe what you're looking
for because maybe you don't know how to
name it or maybe you don't know what it
looks like what you're looking for or
maybe you don't even know what you're
looking for so for example imagine if
you uh read a very interesting article
about your research subject if you're a
researcher and you would like to find
some similar Publications but that have
been published several years ago in the
past or imagine if you would like to
know if some other work is refuting this
article that you find interesting or
imagine if you want to find some other
works that are using the same
experimental procedure as this
interesting article but for all disase
for example well if you are in this
situation um I wish you good luck to
find something with Google or Google
Scholar so in our opinion the user
experience is key in this solution so of
course there have been some innovation
in the field of information research
during the last years like for example
um facet fced filters or similar content
recommendation personalized
recommendation or automatic
classification NLP or entity Rec and
metadata enrichments but every all this
is great and it does help but it's still
not enough in our opinion because most
part of the time it's still designed as
black boxes like magic recommendations
it's still designed to give you a quick
answer rather than give giving you more
exploration
capacity so the design choice of search
and gines um it's it's often uh to limit
what you can access easily and we think
it's not the best way to empower user
when they're looking for some scientific
publication and according to us it's not
a recommendation problem uh to deal with
this discoverability crisis it's not
about improving how artificial
intelligence algorithm will give you the
best free result ever uh because we have
to admit that three result is not enough
when you are looking for Publications uh
in the in your scientific field so
according to us the solution is more
about improving the experience to give
people access to much more information
information than before and to give
people the right tools to be able to
Navigate to navigate inside this very
huge amounts of information but to make
them able to find by themselves relevant
contents and according to us that's the
real Challenge and so how did we work on
this so let's uh share some few elements
of our me methodology so first we always
work with real data and uh in this case
we uh for this prototype we are working
with two data sets
uh the first one is lens covid-19 data
sets uh lens it's an academic search
engine provided by an independent
nonprofit organization they have uh uh
selected several thousand of Articles
and patterns about Corona virus the
second data set is C9 it's the covid-19
open research data sets data sets which
contain more than uh 2,000 scholarly
articles um and it has been created by
the alen Institute for artificial
intelligence so those are the two data
sets we are working on we are doing a
lot of user research uh we're supporting
our experiments with interviews and user
testing with a small group of experts or
researchers we are mixing uh the
different skills in our team all the
time for example designers developers um
statisticians we are all working
together all the time on the same
problems and also um we prototype to
solve problem so rather than specifying
a solution to test uh we want we prefer
to describe problem and each member in
the team is in charge to find solution
to try to test and so in this project
the problems we wanted to solve uh where
how to do something that is um uh that
is good where classic search engines are
not so for example how to allow users to
better understand a corpus as a as a
role or how to help users navig in very
large volumes of content or how to help
users find something that they cannot
describe they don't know how to describe
or how to reduce the fear of missing out
on something
important and we um we have a strong
intuition that mapping can be an
important part of the
solution in fact it was Google Map
rather than Google search so we were
interested in the appearance of Google
Map um and how technology has changed
the use so we read this book which is
really interesting which is called neust
again by Bill K day and there was this
citation that was inspiring for us uh
that that said no one after us no
generation to come will ever be lost in
the way that every generation before was
so our approach was first to try to map
the publication to give an overview of
the Corpus to bring a physical dimension
in because in data visualization
specialization of the information brings
um a tangible and physical Dimension to
data and it plays very positive role in
the ability of people to appropriate
data uh and to play with data and this
is something we have observed since a
long time in a
profession so it helps people
specialization of information it helps
people get a mental picture of the data
it also helps people interact with the
data because they feel more able to get
their hands on because this physical
Dimension it brings uh it it it's it
breaks the blackbox effect and also
specializations uh it also Fosters
memorization and all the theories about
the mental Palace are based on this
observation so armed with this
conviction of mapping can be a solution
we uh wanted to try to what extent this
specialization this localization could
help to better search in scientific
publication so first we have been
looking for the best layout to map the
data set so wanted to find how to get
each publication with a specific
location in the map so try to visualize
this Corpus so we produce a lot of
experiment about how to position the
publication in the physical space um
it's it's it's a bit like if we have um
the data set was like a bowl of clay and
we try to mold the clay to give it a
shape according to specific uh part of
the data
set so at the end of all this test and
this is really a sample of everything
that we tested um at the end we kept two
approaches the first one was a citation
Network graph so the first approach it's
a graph of the sitations link in uh it's
a network graph that means it's it's
built with a force directed layout so
how does it work each not here is a
publication and the publication they are
linked to together we when they are
citing each other so each time a
publication is citing another work we
have those links and we use a physical
simulation where the links act as
attractors it's a bit it's a bit like if
we have some balls that are linked
together by Stretch uh rubber bands and
as you let go all the rubber bands try
to bring the BS together and the systems
stabilize in a way that optimize the
expression of edge link so it gives an
idea of the organization the structure
of the Corpus according to the citations
link and we know that citations links
they are very important in scientific
research because science is made by
iteration and Progressive reputation so
we were really interested in finding a
way uh to make this uh to make visible
this iterative nature of science to show
the making of science thanks to the
station links and also also uh with this
graph we were able to make visible this
dark knowledge in the data set so I
don't know if you have seen it well but
let's me if I don't know if you see the
Cora here at the
periphery of the graph so this Corolla
is made of all the articles that are not
linked to others so the 50% of
publication that are not cited by anyone
else so in this map they are still here
uh we we have this Cora which is the the
dark knowledge that usually you don't
see and here it's it's here at the
border it it remains visible in this in
this
map the second um um experiment the
second way to map this Corpus uh it's a
dimension reduction map so here uh it's
really here where we used machine
learning and here we have another way to
uh organize the data sets we reduce each
publication to a metadata sequence so
it's like a unique sequence of keywords
and information that reflects each
publication so we use
26,000 um different keywords to describe
the Publications and each publication
can be summarized by a sequence of one
and zero describing if each keyword
belongs or not to the publication and
after that we have um so this gives us
um um um vectors in
26,000 Dimensions it's like coordinates
in multi-dimensional space with
26,000 Dimension and then we use a
machine learning algorithm which is
called umap uh to switch position from
this multi-dimensional uh space into a
3D or 2D space so we use umap it's an
algorithm in the same family as tisne
but it's better than tney for our goal
and this kind of algorithm translate
proximity notion in a multi-dimensional
space into proximity uh into a three
diim dimensional space in a way that
articles that are close to each other in
the
26,000 Dimension space are still close
to each other in the two-dimensional
space and articles that were far away in
the multi-dimensional space are still
far away in the 2D space so it's a way
to translate uh 26,000 Dimension into
two Dimension while preserving the
topology so at the end articles uh which
have the closest sequences of keywords
are close to each other in the map so
here the idea was to replicate uh the
physical experience that you have that
you have when you are in the library and
you walk around the the different
shelves and you have a you find a book
that is interesting for you and step by
step close to each other you you look at
uh other
books uh and you will find something
that you are not really looking for so
we add these two ways to draw uh the map
of the
Corpus and we they were both interesting
and so we made some user test to
determine which one was the most easy to
use and to understand and at the end the
dimension map the the reduction the
dimension reduction map was uh really
better understood without any D it was
really clear tester felt more felt more
comfortable with this map they
interacted with it more naturally than
with the sitation graph and also tester
told us that it was easier to understand
it makes more sense for them so we have
seen here the potential of machine
learning for our work at that moment
where we achieve a better organization a
better localization thanks to machine
learning so let's talk about another
point but just let me
find
right just one minute I'm short of
battery right
it's
okay sorry about that my plug was not
working anymore but I'm okay now so uh
something else I wanted to tell you
about it's the colors because uh it's
important to here uh if you see the two
uh Maps the one at the left and the one
at the right H it's there is a huge
difference in your ability to per save
space and um to find some location so we
need to have some colors that are
relevant and here colors are reflecting
clusters so um to get these clusters we
also use a machine learning algorithm um
we use an algorithm that is is called
hdb
scan it's a hierarchical clustering
algorithm
algorithm that means that we are able to
find some parent clust and children
cluster
inside uh and it's a clustering by
density that means that we can identify
some clusters even in complex shapes in
the map and um to um find those
clusters uh we tried different different
implementation of this
algorithm so hdb hdb scan was better
than a usual clustering algorithm like
cam means uh in its ability to detect
complex shapes but you can detect this
complex shape in two Dimension but also
in three dimension uh four dimension and
any of the different uh space we can
create with this uh 20,000
26,000 Dimension we add so we made some
different try different tested and at
the end um we found that implementing
the clustering algorithm in 10
dimensional space was um give us the
best
result just a a small um Point again
about um the color first it's it shows
you the different clusters but also it
can show you some other dimension for
example um sorry just for example here
we can use the color to display to show
the number of sitation
so we can change dynamically the color
of the of the publication and here you
have some other patterns that appears
and for example we are able to see that
the cluster talking about Corona virus
in biology and virology is the most
cited in in this Corpus and just let me
give you few uh explanation about um the
close the
labels so the labels we also find them
uh using some data treatment and here we
try to find
the the most um used uh keywords to
describe the cluster so for example we
found the keywords that are most
frequent in the cluster and not in the
rest of the Corpus or in comparison with
the rest of the
Corpus so let's uh finish with the rest
of the interface because this map is not
working
alone there are some user interface
element to form a tool and give users
some features to explore
further so we have uh like in Google map
the ability to zoom zoom in zoom out or
to pan or to hover any article and see
its link but we have also U the ability
to use some filters so for example it's
really basic because it's just a
prototype and we have been focusing more
on on the map but so you can add some
filters for the gear or for the field of
study or the keywords when hovering a
filter you see directly which part of
the map is concerned and so you can
create this uh filtered version of the
map according to what's important for
you and you can also display the list of
all the publication um and you have this
correspondence between the map and the
list you can investigate further on one
article so you can select an article and
you can see it's uh metadata and the
abstract and everything we get we have
with this article but also you can
explore the citation the citation so
papers which are citing this paper or
references the
bibliography and we can for example
display the list of all the sighting
papers and see where they are on the map
if they are from different fields of
study or if they are from the same
fields of study so this is really um
useful and also we can display a list of
similar Publications so if you find
something that looks good for you we can
automatically um find the closest one
and display the closest
one so this uh is the first prototype we
have been working on and voluntarily we
have not put any search box yet so this
is really
um because we wanted to keep this for
later we wanted first to explore the
potential of the map and the
complementarity between uh the search uh
options like filters and things like
that on the map and so the questions we
ask ourselves is how does it fit
together this map with the user
experience of a classic map like Google
Map and the more classic user exper
experience element like the filters on
the list and we have done user testing
on that and the user test show that
users um still use the map relatively
little as an exploration medium but more
as a feedback um as a way to evaluate
the result of their search as a way to
see uh if the filters they're using is
it relevant for them or not or how many
result they will get or not but for the
moment the map is not really the first
way to interact and to look for
something so this is interesting um but
we would like to see to investigate how
we can um make the most out of this map
for the searching
capacity and so um we have still a long
way to go uh still progress to make to
succeed in this challenge of improving
the research experience in scientific
publication but this is just a first
step The Next
Step uh we would like to try to
visualize relations between entities
extracted from the publication so not
any more mapping the publication and the
relation between articles but mapping
the relation between
entities relation between what articles
are talking about for example we can
extract disease or molecules or viruses
part of the body Gene and so on and all
these entities are discussed inside
publication so if you read one two or
three publication you will see the
relation between those
entities for example you will see that
an article is making a relation between
a virus on a part of the body and a
virus on a gene but you cannot do this
for thousand and thousand of publication
but by automatic extraction and by
visualization specialization we can make
appears the relations between entities
for the whole Corpus and maybe we will
make some correlation appear that you
would not have seen other way because
this is what you can do when you can
visualize such massive amount of
relations so I'm hope um so this will be
our next prototype we are working on it
at the moment and I I really hope I will
be able to share it with you soon and to
give you uh some more feedbacks about
this mapping um capacity to improve the
way we
search so this uh right this is uh the
the end this is the story of what we
have been working on since the beginning
of this
crisis um and I'm um really uh Curious
of your question now so I'm gonna have a
look at the at
the chat
Caroline is James here can you hear me
okay yes I can hear you cool sorry I was
late at the start there was a previous
session that overran um so yeah if
people can send in questions I don't
know whether you can see there are some
questions already in the chat box um
that have been coming through I can see
some people are typing as
well yeah all right I don't know if I go
over the question by order of if
um um I can um I can work backwards if
that's helpful and read out with
questions all right um so question uh
did you experiment with modularity based
clustering methods how did you validate
um or test the Clusters with
users all
right we tried mostly we tried different
algorithm but we were we really wanted
to have a hierarchical clustering
algorithm and so we tried several and we
tested them with users and the the the
the most important thing was how people
feel they can find something in the map
so we were showing the map to you
testers and if they feel they were lost
and if they feel it was like a mess uh
we yeah we were not keeping the
algorithm great thanks um another
question how did you test the layout
algorithm to arrive at the
dimensionality reduction method um was
better yeah it's it's the same
thing um we first we we see what's the
result when we map the uh the the
publication so what's the result of the
algorithm does does it bring something
better in terms of specialization in
terms of capacity to um um to have your
publication that are not all at the same
uh in the same ball at the center but
that are positioned differently in the
space so most mostly um the idea was to
find the best algorithm to create some
space with more uh publication and some
space with the lesson to seiz those
clusters appears so the capacity of
making clusters appear was a a very
important point in our evaluation of the
different algorithm we tried and after
that once when we feel it was good we
show it to our testers and we ask some
feedbacks and we give testers some basic
task of finding uh publication inside
the map or describing the map and we see
which one was more
efficient okay nice um another question
you mentioned that users are less likely
to explore using this map how have you
attempted to enable this
exploration sorry I miss the users are
more likely to um so you mentioned that
users are less likely to explore using
this map so I think the question
question is around what plans do you
have for developing exploration uh
functionality tools
capabilities yeah our idea is really to
have an interface that makes some
rebounds between classic uh filtering
and searching options and the map like
if all the interface was reacting at the
same time when you um perform some
action
so uh for example if you zoom somewhere
in the map it should uh um update at the
same time the filters on the list and if
you feel one filter is interesting for
you it will it should show directly how
part of the map you will lost or if you
um get interested by for example one
article you should be able to see at the
same time uh you can you you you should
be able to read at the same time the
abstract and see what's the impact of
this article uh on the rest of the
scientific field for example so the idea
is giving you more options to go from
one article to another to go from one ID
to another to go from one keyword to
another because it's really complicated
to know which one is the good keyword
for you and this is something that is
really common in the interviews we made
is
that um at the beginning uh people are
are naming things
differently um and according to the
location uh people are describing things
differently in the publication so if you
have to rely only on one two three key
wordss you're really uh there is really
a risk that you miss something and
that's EX exactly the fair of
researchers who are working on a
specific subject uh it's the fair of
missing out some work that have been
already published and that they don't
find because they don't know what is the
correct keyword to find that um and this
is why uh any option to interact with
this Corpus of document that
doesn't uh ask you to describe something
with word but by proximity by going from
one to another clicking here clicking
here to see what's the result it's it's
good perfect thanks thanks Caroline um
that was a really fantastic really
interesting talk um hopefully you've had
a look at some of the compliments in the
chat Channel I think a lot of people
enjoyed that found it really interesting
um I'd ask if um anyone has any
questions further questions for Caroline
just post in the the leaders uh slack um
chat
and uh hopefully she'll be around to
pick that up um so now we're moving on
to um the US time zone uh coverage so we
have the welcome address for the for the
US um part of the conference so um I
would direct people over to there and
we'll we'll get started with handing
over the virtual
baton thanks thanks very much all thanks
Caroline thank you everyone uh I remain
available in the slack channel so do not
hesitate to ask your question uh yeah
great thank you very much